DMT is if DMT didn't exist we would have
to invent it it sort of there has to be
something in the world there has to be a
weirdest thing once we have the concept
of weird there has to be a weirdest
thing and DMT is simply DMT is that
thing which above all other things you
have convinced yourself doesn't exist
it's the one thing you are certain is
impossible that's how it seemed to me if
it completely deconstructs reality in a
completely unexpected way in other words
reality can come apart in many different
ways and if it begins to come apart you
hope it will begin to move along some
traditionally sanctioned spiritual art
you know toward Jesus or heaven or hell
or something identifiable what happens
with DMT is there is an eruption of the
unexpected it seems to be in its nature
to be unexpected and it seems to carry
the message with incredible intensity
that everything you know about reality
is wrong it isn't what you think it is
when you smoked DMT when I smoked DMT
and according to Rick Strassman research
out at New Mexico when most people are
exposed to DMT very quickly like within
30 seconds to a minute you are conveyed
into an inconceivably alien and dramatic
environment of 100% hallucination
nothing you have ever seen before is
there there is nothing there that the
English language can describe because
there is nothing there that any
english-speaking person ever has
encountered before or German or French
or Swahili you you are conveyed into not
a unitary world not the white light the
one or any of that but a unit a complex
multiplicity world of motion light color
depth interaction and none of it makes
very much sense at all it's a metaphor
for what I'm talking about is imagine
that you were a Paleolithic person
getting loaded around the campfire
somewhere on the grasslands of Africa
and imagine that for a minute and a half
you've suddenly found yourself standing
in Times Square at rush hour well you
could sort of make sense I mean when you
came back you would say well there were
people sort of there were sort of people
and then there was a lot of motion and
then there was a lot of verticality and
and but basically you're just thrashing
and clawing the air in front of your
companions they are not getting a
picture of Times Square at rush hour
from this description DMT is like that
it seems to punch through to an
impossible world a parallel dimension
and it's not as if it would be shocking
enough if it were a purely
incomprehensible the problem is it's not
quite purely incomprehensible there's a
2% residual that you seem to be able to
relate to the self dribbling basketball
like entities that I call tight that
come bounding up and leap into your body
and crawl all over you and jump in and
out of your chest Cabot
they are singing in some kind of a
language that you don't hear but see and
so they're singing objects into
existence some kind of musical grammar
is condensing as small pieces of
furniture around you and you have to
remember 30 seconds before you were in
some shabby apartment you and your
strange friends is fiddling with some
drugs and now that's all gone and and
you're you're not sleepy you're not days
you're absolutely who you were that's
the strange thing DMT doesn't affect the
part that we call ourselves say I am who
I was I'm exactly who I was but what the
hell has happened to reality and it's
been entirely replaced by something that
I never saw in any science fiction film
never heard about in any fairy tale
never dreamed of never hinted of and now
I'm fully there and these little
entities are dancing around attention
and then they want you to do something
they want you to sing objects into
existence with your voice and they're
doing it they're showing you how it's
done they somehow grammar is seen in
that world it's as though a switch has
been thrown in your neuro physiological
machinery and language which you use to
hear you now see and these things are
putting a lot of pressure on you saying
do it do it
don't don't question don't think don't
reflect just do it and I sort of feel
something cross between heartburn and
Satori begin to move its way up my chest
and when it come when it reaches my
mouth my mouth fly is open
and this glossolalia like linguistic
stuff begins to happen which is like
language like liquid like silk I can see
it and it's colored and it's complicated
and now I do not understand what this is
for I can join you in speculate it looks
to me like first of all language itself
is a mysterious activity a behavior god
on the on the body of nature human
language is the place to look it is not
anticipated in other forms of animal
organization and in us it reaches this
excruciating level of expression and
with it we have created culture which is
a virtual reality that we surround
ourselves with not only of ideologies
Marxism democracy monarchy but buildings
highways infrastructure so it's almost
as though language is an alien artifact
of some sort
you remember bill burrows said that the
virus from outer space well this is sort
of like that idea but language is
obviously not something that is a
finished enterprise and I think that we
are approaching either through our own
the natural evolution of the soma of the
body or through technology or through
some combination of the two we're
approaching a place where we're going to
switch channels and switch the language
channel into a more broad bandwidth mode
and we're going to see what we mean
instead of here what we mean that the
convention of using small mouth noises
to symbolically indicate objects in the
world
so that those who share the same set of
linguistic assumptions can download this
acoustical babble and reconstruct the
thought out
is going to be traded in for something
more like a direct acoustical hologram
where them
ambiguity is much less prevalent you
know if I read you a paragraph from
Proust we can spend the rest of the
afternoon
discussing what did the author mean
you've all been in those situations what
did the author mean but if I show you a
sculpture by Brancusi we just walk
around and look at it itself evidently
is what it is it does not have the
ambiguity that adheres to written and
spoken language and I think this
ambiguity has allowed misunderstanding
and misunderstanding has allowed pain
and agony so it may be that we're on the
brink of a higher form of language the
descent of the logos this would be if
the manifestation of the logos and the
psychedelics by allowing a look through
the hyperspatial window at future states
of human organization as I argued this
morning it's actually giving us a taste
of a human future that may be far in the
future in the same way that if you had
smoked DMT 20,000 years ago you might
have landed in Times Square circa 1960
it's an insight into a future
development in the physiology and mind
of man and makes it very suggestive then
the DMT is being elaborated in our
brains that's part of normal metabolism
we have genes that produce DMT
well what if those genes were to be
switched on in a more dramatic way then
what would the quality of culture be if
culture is the serotonin trip then what
kind of culture would we live in if the
serotonin were backed out in favor of a
DMT main
neural substrate